she did hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to welcome to
hand well hi I didn't notice you back
there did you do all this work I love it
it's very Jackson Pollock II with all
the blood used together did the splatter
cam loving memory of Graham Foster oh
that's actually a memorial I mean kind
of sweet in the juxtaposition of what
will be a horror game but I like it
nonetheless so this one I found actually
can't remember where I found it it was
mysteriously installed on my desktop and
I have no idea why or how it appears
there but I guess we're just waking up
in a bed again a little bit of a cliche
among horror games I can't move my oh
there we go hello I can see again
ah I love the drab decor hello I'm
trapped and scared and alone and what
the [ __ ] is that sound
hi okay hello oh okay bye then you just
you just gonna leave me here alone in
the darkness in the murder corridor this
is where people die hello
okay alright then I'll just be here
alone oh god you know now that freedom
is an option I don't even know if I want
to get out okay alright
mysterious noises mysterious door this
area is that the surface until further
notice oh good they spray-painted that
across the bars very good and I love the
trail of blood okay do I need to do that
right now or is that like a eventually
kind of thing oh yeah it's working
properly are as good are you crap it
very nice oh no hey
how are you doing are you in timeout
what did you do
were you bad fit you wore if your
timeout in a jail cell holy [ __ ] must be
the worst of the worst yeah destitute Oh
got a head then a head in a fridge
that's a head in a fridge isn't it just
gonna close that up there
no one needs to see that all right hello
Joe the foam broke I need to get on the
warden about why we're down here stuck
with all this [ __ ] falling apart when
the suits upstairs get a brand-new
office plus these guys getting impatient
half of them haven't even had a trial
I'm leaving early all right that [ __ ]
I think you've got the wrong number
okay then all righty ho
huh why is Creed playing in the bathroom
okay all right then I'm gonna get out of
here there was no point in me coming in
here oh boy all right
whoo okay all right [ __ ] high oh it's
just a swingin light and I've seen that
before
you about to illuminate someone in
timeout again yeah okay alrighty then
subtle
I like it subtle I mean I'm waiting for
the eventual extreme scare in my face
but subtle good stuff so Hawking hi okay
bye
was it a ghost okay not very scary not
scary
now would I call spooky but uh pretty
good nonetheless okay never mind then
you're number three let's trying to
contain you nominee [ __ ]
after a failed operation to plug the
gate Ludi report suggests a substantial
loss of life
meanwhile in Hanwell jail many
opportunistic prisoners use the
confusion and scant resources to their
advantage escaping through a weak point
in the recreation yard the doctor could
not be contacted when we reached out for
estate okay thank you
Radio affects position so glad that you
were there to help me along my journey I
feel much oh hey okay yeah he Joe my
guys get tired of the [ __ ] down here
the refills there didn't help making
making money coming in but in a mine 15
spent on luxury feel up there as opposed
to vital equipment down here himself we
may be looking at like if we're not
careful you know we just can't afford
that the council on toilet and also the
doctor of requested team only I've had
to be quite nob you guys about trial on
handlova
and he made all the big people off the
street
yeah Buckley that's 90 there so there
seems to be someone that has some
semblance of justice in this weird world
that were in but I don't know seems like
they're doing the the standard why why
why would you do that why would you do
that to me why would you do that
[ __ ] hi again I would like to say why
would that be a thing that needs to
happen now okay then ah good yes burner
is becoming an issue in little would
criminals using an unproductive 'ti to
cover up burglaries which google breeder
transferred what kind of world do we
live in to 296 okay so if I'm not I'm
not mistaken this is a
this is where we just were wait that
one's locked but there's an arrow
pointing down right by that bathroom but
it was just a bunch of lockers over
there so does that mean that there's
like a secret door over there okay ah
this is a witch breeder ooh oh hello oh
good its development of the game oh
that's kind of clever I like that
anything else on these No all right
council fallen hand well compromise by
the Oktar the doctor is dead the council
has fallen we are all trapped within
these concrete slabs of grey oppression
where we go for me is unclear well and
well is no longer the bastion of safe
living anymore okay it didn't feel like
a bastion of safe living as it stands
now so why would it be then okay all
right then you know I'm a how about take
this key and I'll find where it goes you
is is your door nope is hi oh okay all
right then Oh can I let the person out
of timeout and I let them out of timeout
that seems like it'd be a bad idea okay
all right then you know I'm gonna go for
it
never mind I didn't want to do all of
them Oh timeout lady
no nanana nanana nanana nanana nanana
now don't think he can do that to me
you think you can do that to me you
think you can just do that to me huh
Do You Know Who I am do you know how
many horror games I've screamed at the
minor to moderate effectiveness huh you
think I won't scream at you okay there
was something in here before but
apparently not now okay these showers
are lovely [ __ ]
all right come on yeah who'll be there
huh someone's going back in the naughty
corner real soon where there's something
- now it seems like there might have
been at some point okay here we go
skedaddling you glad to know that still
malfunctioning so why were you I know
it's probably not a good idea to go in
that cell but why were you in timeout
huh
why okay walking hi hello hello hi okay
alright then I'm gonna go to the outer
surface area covered in oceans of blood
oh this is a bad hallway so there behind
me isn't it right okay alright then
everything's fine freedom this way oh I
believe you I believe you thought my
heart if you can get past the [ __ ] I'm
gonna assume you meant to write which Oh
alrighty then I've got a flashlight and
a bang bang err I'm all swag swag my
prank bang her up against your skull put
you in timeout forever permanently Oh
[ __ ] you are she is she dad yes you
do alrighty then
crouching eliminates the sound of your
footsteps I don't like that oh no always
just poop on the floor go faster Crouch
she crew ohh
what is up my crowd decroux
well that didn't work I think she pushed
IV she bumped me into the tunnel that I
was supposed to be in but the somehow
that didn't work
oddly enough Hey ah ah
come on go down here I'll go down here
down here yes yes yes yes yes yes it
worked I think maybe honey no hello
ah I seem to have left my crowbar
alrighty then at least I'm going down to
this amnesia esque hallway of caverns
and tunnels but where's they're gonna
lead me down at the bottom but also so
there's not a witch breeder look what
does that even mean like Earth Hey
you know after I just encountered a
ghost lady you think snakes are actually
gonna bother me or scorpions or whatever
the hell that was huh
I'm a big strong brave boy you ain't
gonna mess with me okay that's not as
good as I thought it was gonna be
that's actually the opposite exactly the
opposite of good Bob I did skedaddle
this way go by me I just like to
skedaddle with great frequency excuse my
spit
[Music]
at the end yeah you gotta do it you
gonna do that
yeah that's the end okay all right then
Nathan seed house I see how you breathe
okay go anyway
that was welcome to handler it's pretty
good
I got it man we did they did a pretty
good job here there's actually good
animation work good environment work
good potential for something good here
so like with all these demos I'm gonna
go ahead and say I would like to see a
lot more of this game but I don't know
when that's going to be so either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll put a link to this game down in the
comments or the description below and
hopefully I can find more about this
game later on I hope you guys enjoyed it
let me know what you think and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]